I'm going to take something a blogger
said now I know it's different from what
you're doing with your screenplay
but I read medium.com a lot and there's
a gentleman on there named John
westenberg and he publishes a lot of his
blogs and his latest blog at the DL from
the other day was my secret to
publishing every single day I stick to
three drafts and he says I realize here
over here in his tips I'm sorry he said
I only ever allow myself three drafts on
any blog post this rule stops me from
chasing perfection it stops me from
second-guessing it makes me think
carefully about what I'm doing and it
stops me from rambling pointlessly so I
know three drafts for a screenplays
different but are there certain rules
where you you just you say okay I have
to stop at this because we're just kind
of just we stop when we're on deadline
yeah there's always a point like before
we have to turn it in there's like okay
and then you just back engineer it
you're like okay here's where we're
going to have to turn it in so here's
where we're going to have to send it to
my mom to spellcheck now or somebody
it's dead like that by the way who is
looking at it well the deadline the
deadline that we're looking at right now
is a dream ago deadline and and that is
after we finished the Switzerland the
Switzerland process they gave us all of
these notes because they chose to chose
our script because it was awesome
clearly but they also chose our scripts
because they feel like it has the
potential to be more awesome and you
know so they give you a lot to do and so
they aren't necessarily picking you
because I think you're ready and you're
complete and it's the best thing ever
they're picking it for you know for its
promise and maybe it's something that
they can kind of nurture as they go
along so you get two months after the
end of the Switzerland thing to revise
you know you've taken in all of the
wisdom and you review revise July 31st
is the deadline and and if at that point
they're feeling like it's it's ready to
show producers or whatever the
they'll come out for afm and they try to
set up a few meetings if they can for
you and and it's called meet your match
and I think I'm not sure how formal it
is but you know we'd like for it to be
ready for that because that would be a
great opportunity and if they don't feel
like it's ready at that point and you
can try for another year and turn it in
but because we're you know celebrating
our three-year anniversary I think we'd
really like to have a good revision yeah
I think why the way I said John Wester
John West John Weston Bergen it's Jo Ann
and then westenberg calm oh yeah well I
think John John westenberg
three drafts for a blog post is just
about perfect I usually send it after
two and then I see it and have to go
back and like do another pass because
I'm appalled that I've sent it out with
so many typos but you know it's enough
to Keanu keep the voice you you know you
you do it and then you let a day pass or
whatever you can kind of go and and
start you know cut a few things out so
that you don't ramble too much and then
that sort of thing I think that's about
perfect but for I think it's hard with
the screenplay you're really somebody
there's some quote about it that you
know it's it's never done until it gets
made and then it's done when somebody
rips it out of your hands right is
basically when it's done yeah and I
think that you know even talking to
documentary filmmakers or other
filmmakers it really is in terms of the
collaborative process it's still going
on because even after we finish this
draft there will be notes that we will
get from other people or producers or
director and so the process is done when
it goes to screen because there's the
editing process that I think goes on
after we've written it and we've shot it
so understanding all that you know from
from a screenwriting standpoint though
for us it does tend to be definite the
wheat have been pretty much all three
years we've been working on it on
deadline force
something either a competition or our
producing partner has a deadline where
he would like to see you know a certain
thing done
so we've tended to write to deadlines
most yeah you don't always know you're
writing the deadline at the beginning
you're like oh we have so much time
we're just writing and then the deadline
gets closer at 1:00 there are times when
I'm rant and she's busy for times that
she's ready to go and I've got stuff and
so I think we are able to balance the
different parts of this partnership in
ways that when I have to slack off she
can pick it up when she can't work I'm
on the go with it
so you know it it's you know it's like I
think we have a yin and yang about us
that that seems to work and you know
Barrington has an outside work life my
work life is here and so I can move and
flow in a different kind of way I can
edit in the morning I can edit at night
I can edit during the middle of the day
she has to be someplace from 12:00 to
5:00 and so you know we respect and
honor that because that's how she makes
our money so she pays our bills and so
for me it's easier because I don't I'm
not beholding to a particular place so
but then Barrington's got the energy of
that little bunny with the batteries I
love you know I haven't I've pretty good
like you know one time on task I have a
I have a certain amount of persistence
for that and I think you don't really
know what's slowing you down sometimes
I'm sure it works both ways I think you
know sometimes Janice will like will be
working on something that maybe feels
like it's a little bit off topic or
something and I tend you know and I'm
always trying to like
para way and like you know I have less
patience for that kind of thing because
I'm like I want to be writing and so
like I'm tired of talking about things I
want to be writing but she's like but
wait I need to tell you this and this
and also I made me think about this and
I'm like it's too much but then when you
get to the page you never know what you
might need you know and that's and and
so sometimes like things that I was
impatient in the moment about I'm like
oh that little detail is totally going
to make it so and and you don't know how
long it would have taken you to come up
with that if you hadn't you know taking
the time to do that groundwork so yeah
so it's just a time-consuming process
running screenplays a time-consuming
process
you